IS CALLED SECTION TWO THIRTY.
AND I BELIEVED IN THE
PRINCIPLES OUTLINED IN THE LAW.
BUT IT IS CLEAR THAT SECTION
TWO THIRTY IN ITS CURRENT FORM
IS NO LONGER WORKING. JUST LAST
WEEK JUSTICE CLARENCE THOMAS
SAID THE COURTS HAVE READ
SWEEPING NEW PROTECTIONS IN THE
TWO THIRTY THAT CONGRESS NEVER
PUT INTO STATUTE. IT IS TIME TO
SCRAP THE LAW AND START OVER.
YESTERDAY THE NEW YORK POST ONE
OF THE COUNTRY'S LARGEST
NEWSPAPERS PUBLISHED A PIECE ON
HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS WORK ON
THE BOARD OF UKRAINIAN ENERGY
COMPANY VERY SMART. WHICH HE
HAD NO QUALIFICATIONS FOR. IT
IS AN IMPORTANT STORY AS MOST
AMERICANS WOULD BE APPALLED BY
THE VICE PRESIDENT'S SON USING
HIS FATHER'S POSITION TO EARN
AN ENORMOUS CONTRACT FROM
FOREIGN COMPANIES. BUT THE
RESPONSE FROM MANY IN THE MEDIA
ON TWITTER AND FACEBOOK BRING
TO LIGHT AN EVEN BIGGER CONCERN.
THE BIGGEST SOCIAL NETWORKS ARE
SELECTIVELY CENSORING
INFORMATION. IF YOU ARE A
CITIZEN AND POSTED INFORMATION
IN THE STORY YOUR ACCOUNT WAS
LOCKED LAST NIGHT THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE POSTED THE STORY ON
THEIR WEBSITE. A GOVERNMENT
WEBSITE. AND THIS MORNING
TWITTER HAS CENTERED. THE BIG
TECH CENSOR THE MEDIA AMERICANS
WHEN THEY POSTED ABOUT THE
UNVERIFIED AND LATER TO BOX
STILL DOSSIER. DID BIG TECH
CENSOR THE MEDIA ON AMERICANS
WHEN THEY POSTED ABOUT TRUMP'S
TAXES. WHICH WERE OF COURSE
OBTAINED ILLEGALLY. DID BIG
TECH SENSOR THE WORLD'S LARGEST
SPONSOR OF TERRORISM THE
SUPREME LEADER OF IRAN. THEY
ANSWERED ALL THREE QUESTIONS IS
NOW. SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
INTEND TO USE THE PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED BY CONGRESS FOR SOME
AMERICANS BUT NOT FOR OTHERS WE
SHOULD REMOVE THOSE SPECIAL
STANDARDS ALTOGETHER. NOW
RANKING MEMBER JIM JORDAN IN
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HAVE LEGISLATION SHOULD BE
VOTED ON RESTORE FREE
EXPRESSION. AND AMERICANS TOWN
SQUARES. REPUBLICANS ARE CLEAR
ON WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO SERVE
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
REPUBLICANS ARE PART OF OUR
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA HAVE BEEN
CLEAR HOW WE WOULD RESTORE WAY
OF LIFE REBUILD THE ECONOMY AND
WE KNEW THE AMERICAN DURING.
CHIEF AMONG OUR GOALS IS
KEEPING SMALL BUSINESSES OPEN
AND EMPLOYEES ON PAYROLL. I
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO HAVE A
DRINK. I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
HAVE A DREAM TO HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS. IN FACT WE HAVE BEEN
RELENTLESS IN OUR PUSH TO GET
SPEAKER PELOSI. TO PROVIDE
NEEDED RELIEF FOR AMERICANS.
SHE CONTINUES THE TURNER BACK
IN FOCUS ON POLITICS NOT PEOPLE.
EIGHTY ONE DAYS AGO ONE SPEAKER
PELOSI WAS ASKED THAT THE HOUSE
WILL STAY IN SESSION UNTIL A
DEAL IS NEGOTIATED SHE ANSWERED
WE CAN'T GO HOME WITHOUT. A FEW
DAYS LATER SHE SENT US HOME FOR
THE AUGUST RECESS WITH NO DEAL.
REPUBLICANS HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
BRING UP SMALL BUSINESS
COMMITTEE RANKING MEMBER SKI
SHOP IT'S LEGISLATION TO REOPEN
PAYCHECK PROTECTION TO SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES. AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES. BUT DEMOCRATS HAVE
BLOCKED ANY PPP. MONEY GOING
FORWARD THIRTY NINE TIMES.
THAT'S THIRTY NINE TIMES WE
BROUGHT IT TO THE FLOOR THAT
THEY HAVE VOTED NO ON. SPEAKER
PELOSI DOES NOT WANT TO LIFT A
FINGER TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BECAUSE SHE BELIEVES
THAT OUR OWN WORDS AND LET ME
QUOTE. THAT NOTHING IS BETTER
THAN SOMETHING AND TO GO SHE
ASIANS ARE ALL ABOUT LEVERAGE.
IT IS CLEAR. SHE HAS OFFERED
RESISTANCE INSTEAD OF RELIEF.
AND SHE HAS WASTED PRECIOUS
TIME THIS YEAR. EATING ICE
CREAM IN FRONT OF A
REFRIGERATOR BLAMING A SALON
OWNER FOR HER SPECIAL
TREATMENT. ANNOUNCED SLOPING
WOLF BLITZER. THESE ARE NOT THE
ACTIONS OF A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY. BUT
THAT'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. YES
SIR- THE PRESIDENT KEEPS
TALKING ABOUT IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SEE CONGRESS GO BIG OR GO
HOME- COULD BE RELEASED BILL I
THINK ADMINISTRATION'S OFFER
SUMMER OF ONE POINT EIGHT
TRILLION RIGHT NOW HE'S TALKING
ABOUT GOING EVEN HIGHER THAN
THAT. WHITE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT AT ONE POINT EIGHT
TRILLION FOR BIGGER DEAL IF
THAT'S REACHED BETWEEN THE
SPEAKER AND THE WHITE HOUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT'S MOST INTERESTING
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT ONE POINT
EIGHT IS A VERY BIG DEAL. A
LARGE AT THAT'S A BIG DEAL BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NANCY PELOSI
STILL MAKES US GO HOME INSTEAD
OF. GETTING SOMETHING DONE. I
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD
WANT ANYTHING TO HAVE TO GO
FORWARD REPUBLICANS HAVE TIME
AND AGAIN. PUSHED FORWARD SIDE
IDEAS FORWARD UNFORTUNATELY THE
SPEAKER CONTROLS THE HOUSE. THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION. IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT OUR ANSWER
WOULD BE BECAUSE THE SPEAKER
HAS DENIED ANYTHING FROM
MOVING. EVEN HER ALL. HER
MEMBERS TO VOTE FOR A ONE POINT
EIGHT TRILLION DOLLARS YOU KNOW
I'VE ALWAYS RIGHT ALWAYS READ A
BILL BEFORE I ENCOURAGE ANYBODY
WILL FOR ANYTHING BUT- WHAT'S
INTERESTING TO ME AS HER OWN
MEMBERS THAT DEMOCRATS. HAVE
ASKED HER TO TAKE THIS DEAL.
SHE IS THE ONLY HURDLE THE ONLY
ROADBLOCK TO US EVEN BEING ABLE
TO VOTE ON SOMETHING. WE HAVE A
DISCHARGE PETITION. THAT WOULD
REMOVE PPP MONEY THAT'S SITTING
THERE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS. SHE OF FORCED
HER MEMBERS NOT TO SIGN.
THERE'S ONE STUMBLING BLOCK TO
ANY DEAL GETTING THROUGH IT
DOESN'T MATTER THE SIZE. THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS THE
ONLY ONE THIS THE NINTH. IF YOU
HAVE ANY LIKE WHAT'S YOUR CAN
YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE WILL BE
A COVID REALLY FEEL I KNOW WE
KEEP ASKING THIS QUESTION WILL
THERE BE A COVID REALLY FEEL
PRETTY AMERICAN PEOPLE BEFORE
THE ELECTION. AS LONG AS
SPEAKER PELOSI'S INVOLVED I
THINK THE ANSWER IS EASILY NOW.
HE WATCHED HER EVERY SINGLE
TIME WE'VE TRIED TO HAVE COVID
RELIEF SHE'S ALWAYS HELD THE
PROCESS UP. NOW SHE STRANGLING
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC BY DENYING
ANYTHING MOVING YOU WATCHED
EVEN HER. ARGUING WITH WOLF
BLITZER. BECAUSE HE WANTED TO
READ QUOTES FROM HER OWN
MEMBERS ASKING HER TO TAKE THE
DEAL. I THINK SHE CARES MORE
ABOUT POLITICS. THAT SHE CARES
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC IT'S
OBVIOUS WITH HER ACTIONS
REMEMBER WHY SHE SAID SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO GO FORWARD SHE
IS FEARFUL THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WOULD GET A CHECK. FEARFUL THAT
THE PRESIDENT WOULD GET SOME
CREDIT INSTEAD OF HELPING THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC IN THIS TIME OF
NEED. YES QUESTION REGARDING ON
CALL NINETEEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE
TO DEAL IS- APPROVE BONNEVILLE
GOES THE SATURDAY AND YOU'RE
NOT TO HAVE TO COME BACK WHAT
IS YOUR PLAN TO KEEP OUR
MEMBERS AND THEIR STAFFS SAY
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS WELL
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION YOU'LL
KNOW ABOUT FOUR FIVE MONTHS AGO
I PUT A REPORT OUT ALONG WITH
RODNEY DAVIS AND TOM COLE ON
HOW WE COULD KEEP THE HOUSE
SAFE ONE OF THAT ELEMENT'S WITH
TESTING UNFORTUNATELY SPEAKER
PELOSI HAS DENIED THAT- THE
PROTECTIONS ON WHICH COMMITTEES
WOULD BRING BACK THE SIZE OF
STAFF WHICH WOULD BRING BACK.
UNFORTUNATELY SPEAKER PELOSI
HAS DENIED ALL THE BUILDINGS
WERE WE WORK WITH A LOT OF THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY TO COME WITH
A PLAN TO KEEP THE HOUSE. SAFE
ONE OF THOSE WOULD BE TESTING.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND HAVE
A GOOD ACT.